This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。欢迎收听Look Back at it播客。1979年对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及喜爱的作家。比如马特·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯为您带来的《用最难的方式去学》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《用最难的方式去学》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。成群的网络侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷g，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners,
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众们，
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode, back for another topic. Today you've read the title, you will know that we are talking about dating apps. And I think the new reality of dating in your 20s is that dating apps are invariably going to be part of your story or sometimes even your dating. daily life if you're a single. And it's also probably one of the primary ways that a lot of us meet new individuals and form romantic connections. It's actually really interesting that it has taken over and really become one of the primary ways that people are meeting, I guess, the loves of their lives and the main people that they date in their 20s. There was a study
老听众们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一集节目，探讨另一个话题。今天，大家看了标题就会知道，我们在谈论约会软件。我认为二十几岁约会的新现实是，约会软件不可避免地会成为你故事的一部分，如果你是单身，有时甚至会成为你日常生活的一部分。这可能也是我们许多人结识新朋友和建立恋爱关系的主要途径之一。实际上非常有趣的是，它已经接管并真正成为了人们结识彼此（我猜是他们一生的挚爱）的主要途径之一，也是他们在二十几岁时约会的主要对象。曾有一项研究
conducted by the Pew Research Centre and it found that almost half of us between 18 and 29 have used a dating app and we have all heard the stories of people finding the loves of their lives, their future spouses on these sites sometimes even when they weren't looking and you know I can't really say anything because I met my boyfriend on hinge and he is incredible so I'm definitely one of the success stories, despite the fact that for a long time, I kind of had it out for dating apps a little bit. I thought that they were so mentally exhausting and fruitless that everyone on there had such different intentions and varied intentions that you could never really meet anyone serious. But I have since changed my mind.
由皮尤研究中心进行，研究发现，在18至29岁的人群中，近一半的人使用过约会软件，我们都听说过人们在这些网站上找到一生挚爱、未来伴侣的故事，有时甚至在他们并没有刻意寻找的时候。你知道，我也没什么好说的，因为我在Hinge上遇到了我的男朋友，他非常棒，所以我绝对算是一个成功的故事，尽管在很长一段时间里，我对约会软件其实有点反感。我曾认为它们极其消耗精神且毫无结果，上面每个人的意图都大不相同、各不相同，你永远无法真正遇到认真的人。但我后来改变了主意。
And I think the way that we approach how we use dating apps to meet new people really defines the experience that we'll have on them. you know, Tinder, hinge, Bumble, especially apps that exist on our phone, they have completely changed how we approach dating, specifically by how they have profoundly expanded our options for who we can meet. Because the uptake of these apps has been so massive, you know, it used to be that your only romantic options were really limited to friends of friends or co-workers or, you know, Dave at the local bar and now you can kind of meet anyone, not just the people who live down the street or go to your church, but people who live overseas. You could go on a date in every country
我认为我们对待约会软件的态度，以及我们如何利用它们来结识新朋友，真正决定了我们在上面的体验。你知道，Tinder、Hinge、Bumble，特别是那些存在于我们手机里的软件，它们彻底改变了我们的约会方式，具体表现在它们极大地扩展了我们可以结识的对象范围。由于这些软件的普及率如此之高，你知道，过去你的恋爱对象真的仅限于朋友的朋友、同事，或者本地酒吧的戴夫，而现在你基本上可以结识任何人，不仅是那些住在街区尽头或去同一教堂的人，还有住在海外的人。如果你愿意，
if you wanted to. You could meet people you might never encounter. Go on a date every night of the week if that's your cup of tea. And I just really think that that is something we couldn't do 20, 30 years ago. I think part of the inherent appeal of dating apps is not just the number of choices it provides us, but kind of the ease at which we can now dip our toes in and out of the dating pool in an extremely convenient way, often from, you know, the comfort of sitting on your couch or in bed. It's interesting because I think that dating apps actually represent this like broader societal shift towards convenience and efficiency. You know, we have apps like Uber Eats or Deliveroo for getting, you know, food delivered in 10 minutes or Amazon for when you really need that new clothing item or thing at your door in 24 hours.
你可以在每个国家都约会一次。你可以结识那些你可能永远不会遇到的人。如果这合你的胃口，你甚至可以一周七天每天都去约会。我真的认为这是20、30年前我们无法做到的事情。我认为约会软件固有的吸引力的一部分，不仅在于它为我们提供的选择数量，还在于我们现在可以以一种极其便利的方式轻松涉足约会池，通常只需坐在舒适的沙发上或躺在床上就能做到。有趣的是，我认为约会软件实际上代表了更广泛的社会转向便利和效率的趋势。你知道，我们有Uber Eats或Deliveroo来确保在10分钟内送达食物，或者当你的门廊急需新衣服或某件物品时，有亚马逊在24小时内送达。
And of course, we have dating apps. We have almost made finding love convenient, digital, online, something that you could do from the comfort of your own home. And you could join at 7 a.m., be out for drinks by 6pm. that is the appeal of these kind of platforms. I think not only have they changed the number of options and the ease at which we can tap into this like infinite source of potential matches, but they've also shifted our behavioral approach to dating beyond just online swiping. They've kind of changed how we date in real life.
当然，我们也有约会软件。我们几乎把寻找爱情变成了一件便捷的、数字化的、在线的事情，你可以在自己舒适的家中完成。你可以在早上7点注册，下午6点就出去喝酒。这就是这类平台的吸引力所在。我认为它们不仅改变了选择的数量和我们获取这种潜在匹配源源不断的能力，还改变了我们对约会的行为方式，超越了单纯的在线左划右划。它们在某种程度上改变了我们在现实生活中的约会方式。
And I think they've done this in both good and bad ways. and many ways that psychology can explain. So firstly, dating apps allow us to be very specific with our preferences, which may actually make us more closed off to real-life connection. So when we think about things like Tinder or Hinge, you can essentially choose your age range, you can choose your height preferences, even race, and all of these decisions that you're making,
我认为它们在好的和坏的方面都产生了这种影响。心理学可以解释其中的许多方面。首先，约会软件允许我们对自己的偏好设定得非常具体，这实际上可能会让我们对现实生活中的连接更加封闭。因此，当我们想到像Tinder或Hinge这样的软件时，你基本上可以选择你的年龄范围、身高偏好，甚至是种族，你所做出的所有这些决定，
they are based on what we think we are attracted to. And there are many, many theories as to where these romantic preferences come from, but also why they might not be completely accurate. So often we go into these online environments, wanting someone who is 6-2 and someone who is from our neighbourhood and someone who is X, Y, Z, A, B, C, and really, that might not always put us in the best position to meet someone we actually connect with. So we all have this inherent preference, right? And this preference comes from things like genetics. So the role of genetics is actually
它们都基于我们认为自己被吸引的对象。关于这些浪漫偏好的来源，有非常非常多的理论，但也有关于为什么它们可能并不完全准确的理论。通常我们进入这些在线环境时，希望找到一个身高6尺2寸、来自我们社区、符合X、Y、Z、A、B、C条件的人，而实际上，这并不总能让我们处于结识真正合得来的人的最佳位置。所以我们都有这种固有的偏好，对吧？这种偏好来自遗传等因素。因此，基因的作用实际上
pretty important. One of the most fascinating theories focusing on the psychology behind who we find attractive is known as genetic imprinting. So according to this theory, we subconsciously seek out romantic partners who resemble our parents. Now this behavior is thought to be an evolutionary thing, an evolutionary preference that helps ensure genetic compatibility and it increases the likelihood of producing healthy offspring. You know, it also comes down to things like hormones and pheromones, and it's closely linked to the Freudian idea of the Oedipus and Oediple Complex. I actually don't like this theory, I think that it's really strange to suggest that we are only ever attracted to people who mimic our parents, not just from a weird, almost vaguely incestuous way, but also because I think that it doesn't
相当重要。关于我们被谁吸引背后的心理学，最迷人的理论之一被称为基因印记。根据这个理论，我们在潜意识里寻找长相酷似我们父母的伴侣。这种行为被认为是一种进化现象，一种有助于确保基因相容性并增加产生健康后代可能性的进化偏好。你知道，它还归结于荷尔蒙和信息素等因素，并且与弗洛伊德关于俄狄浦斯和俄狄浦斯情结的想法密切相关。其实我不太喜欢这个理论，我认为暗示我们只会被模仿父母的人吸引是非常奇怪的，不仅因为这有一种奇怪的、几乎是含糊不清的乱伦意味，还因为它认为
really allow for the idea of couples who aren't heterosexual. There's also a lot of stuff to do with things like race. You know, if you are someone who is Caucasian, this theory says that you inherently can't be attracted to someone who is a different race to you, which we know very well is absolutely not correct. So it is one theory, not the full picture. I think our preferences also come from things like familiarity and similarity. We are more attracted to people we already feel similar to or who we share a common interest with because we interpret that similarity to mean that we have shared values and therefore that we are more compatible. Even deeper than that is this theory that we are attracted to people who we see as being equally attractive as us. So more colloquially,
这并没有真正为非异性恋情侣留出空间。这里面也有很多关于种族的事情。你知道，如果你是一个白人，这个理论表明你本质上不可能被一个不同种族的人吸引，而我们非常清楚这绝对是不正确的。所以这只是一个理论，而不是全貌。我认为我们的偏好也来自熟悉度和相似性等因素。我们更容易被那些我们已经感到相似或与我们有共同兴趣的人吸引，因为我们把这种相似性解释为我们拥有共同的价值观，因此我们更具相容性。比这更深层的理论是，我们会被那些我们认为与我们具有同等吸引力的人吸引。更通俗地说，
we would say that is being attracted to someone who is in our league. And that kind of comes from the influence of self-esteem and not wanting to put yourself in a place where you can feel or are rejected, so you seek out people who you think are on a similar level to you in terms of the attributes that people find attractive. You know, culture, family, it also plays a role in who we think will be, you know, not only a physical match, but also an emotional match. And so we make our selections on dating apps based on this preconceived notion of who we see ourselves with in the future. But these preferences are not always accurate, and they also change over time. So research that has been published in the personality and psychology bulletin, it followed over 200
我们会说这是被和我们在同一水平线上的人吸引。这在一定程度上源于自尊心的影响，因为不想让自己处于可能感到被拒绝或实际被拒绝的境地，所以你会寻找那些你认为在人们觉得有吸引力的特质方面与你处于相似水平的人。你知道，文化、家庭，它们也在我们认为谁不仅是身体上的绝配、而且是情感上的绝配方面发挥着作用。因此，我们在约会软件上的选择是基于这种先入为主的概念，即我们认为未来会和什么样的人在一起。但这些偏好并不总是准确的，它们也会随着时间而改变。因此，发表在《个性与心理学通报》上的一项研究追踪了200多名
participants for 13 years. And what they found was that our conception of the ideal partner will transform as we get older. Specifically, we begin to reduce our value on things like attractiveness or we stop focusing on particular physical features. And there are certain treats that become more attractive to us, specifically when it comes to looking for trying to find a long-term partner. So how does this kind of relate back to the dating app theory, the dating app, zeitgeist? Well, the basic premise of these apps is that you don't need to meet people in person unless you want to. You can do it all online. And so we make judgments about someone's personality and their inherent compatibility with us based on a very limited information that is coming from
参与者长达13年。他们发现的是，随着年龄的增长，我们对理想伴侣的观念会发生转变。具体来说，我们开始降低对外表等事物的重视程度，或者不再关注特定的身体特征。有些特质对我们变得更有吸引力，特别是在寻找长期伴侣时。那么，这与约会软件理论、约会软件时代精神有什么关系呢？嗯，这些软件的基本前提是，除非你想，否则你不需要亲自见人。你可以在网上完成这一切。因此，我们根据非常有限的信息来判断某人的个性和他们与我们的内在相容性，这些信息可能来自
potentially a highly curated profile. And we also make a judgment based on our misguided preferences. I always say this, but I think that you will never know whether someone is right for you unless you actually have the chance to meet them. Obviously, there are some huge red flags that we can make a pretty snap judgment around. But because of of how many choices these apps present us, often we actually end up ignoring or dismissing people based on their profile who actually could have been great for us. Another element of this is not feeling like you actually have a connection with any of your matches because you are so overwhelmed by choice. It's kind of the reverse of what we call the scarcity effect. So when something is
一个高度精心策划的个人资料。我们还会根据我们被误导的偏好做出判断。我总是这么说，但我认为，除非你真正有机会见到某人，否则你永远不会知道这个人是否适合你。显然，有一些巨大的红旗信号可以让我们做出非常迅速的判断。但由于这些软件给我们带来了如此多的选择，我们最终往往会根据个人资料而忽视或解雇那些实际上可能非常适合我们的人。这其中的另一个因素是，由于你被选择淹没，你觉得与任何一个匹配对象都没有真正的连接。这有点像我们所说的稀缺效应的逆转。因此，当某事物
limited or rare like a romantic connection, we value it more. But when something is plentiful and there is a very large supply like matches in a big city, we value each of those matches the potential for a romantic connection within each of those. We value that a whole lot less. Have you ever had that experience of chatting with a bunch of people on dating apps? And then one of them organizes a date and you have to like go back and remind yourself what their name was or you like completely forget what they look like when their friends ask or just feeling really overwhelmed by your options. That is reflective of an experience known as choice overload, which we have spoken about on the show before. Essentially, we find it really difficult to make a choice when we're presented with too many
有限或稀有时，比如浪漫的连接，我们会更加珍视它。但当某事物很丰富且供应量非常大时，比如大城市里的匹配对象，我们会对每一个匹配对象以及其中产生浪漫连接的可能性大大降低其价值。你是否曾有过这样的经历：在约会软件上和一群人聊天？然后其中一个人安排了一场约会，你不得不回去提醒自己他们的名字是什么，或者当朋友问起时你完全忘记了他们长什么样，或者只是对你的选择感到不知所措。这反映了一种被称为选择过载的体验，我们在节目中以前讨论过。本质上，当我们面对太多
options and that kind of seems a little bit counterintuitive. You know, surely as humans, we want more options so that we don't feel limited by our choices. But actually, no, our brains can only process so much information at once. So when we are on a dating app and there are thousands of potential people that we might find a little bit attractive, we might get along with, we might see a future with, we can actually become paralyzed by all those choices and we can't take any action. This may explain why a lot of us don't actually end up meeting the people we might. match with or translating those online interactions into real dates. So there was a study that I found when looking into this that was actually really interesting when it comes to this point. And what
选择时，我们会发现很难做出选择，这似乎有点违背直觉。你知道，作为人类，我们当然希望有更多的选择，这样我们就不会觉得自己的选择受限。但实际上，并非如此，我们的大脑一次只能处理有限的信息。因此，当我们身处约会软件中，有成千上万个我们可能会觉得有点吸引力、可能会合得来、可能会看到未来的潜在人选时，我们实际上可能会被所有这些选择弄得瘫痪，以至于无法采取任何行动。这或许可以解释为什么我们中的许多人最终并没有去见那些我们匹配过的人，或者没有把那些网络互动转化为真实的约会。因此，我在研究这个问题时发现了一项研究，在这一点上实际上非常有趣。它所说的
it said was that some 48% of people who are currently using swipe-based dating apps, so Tinder, hinge, basically, they have met up with less than five people in the past year. And half of those people have never even met anyone, despite using the apps continuously. And these are, you know, these people who are frequently swiping. They are frequently looking around, matching with people. So besides from Choice Overload, why is that so common? Why do we use dating apps if we're not using them for their original purpose, which is to Neo, date or maybe find love? I think the biggest explanation for that is validation.
是，目前使用基于左划右划的约会软件（也就是Tinder、Hinge等）的人中，大约有48%的人在过去一年里见不到五个人。而这些人中有的一半甚至从未见过任何人，尽管他们一直在持续使用这些软件。而这些人呢，是那些频繁左划右划的人。他们经常环顾四周，与人匹配。那么，除了选择过载之外，为什么这种情况如此普遍？如果我们使用约会软件不是为了它们的最初目的（即约会或寻找真爱），我们为什么要使用它们呢？我认为最大的解释是获得认可。
Maybe we have a bit of a bruised ego. We've just been through a bad breakup. And if we're honest with ourselves, we're not actually ready to date again. But seeing those matches and those likes and the people who think that we're attractive is a confidence boost. It's validating to know that people think that you're hot or people think that you're cute. And in our society, attractiveness is often associated with self-worth. And so we find that we feel a lot better about ourselves without ever even having to meet these people.
也许我们的自尊心有点受挫。我们刚刚经历了一段糟糕的分手。如果我们对自己诚实，我们其实并没有准备好再次约会。但是看到那些匹配、那些点赞以及那些认为我们很有吸引力的人，是一剂自信心的强心剂。得知别人认为你很火辣或很可爱，是很有肯定意义的。在我们的社会中，吸引力通常与自我价值联系在一起。因此，我们发现自己对自己的感觉好多了，甚至根本不需要去见这些人。
So 61% of respondents in this same study said that they were more interested in discovering who was attracted to them online than actually going out with anyone. And obviously I think we need to do a little bit more research into this would be a really fascinating follow-up study. But I think what this initial finding shows us is that dating apps may be more of a source of public affirmation than actually romantic potential. I have a theory as to why that might be the case, and it has to do with what I would call the gamification of dating through the existence of dating apps. And I don't think that that was intentional. You know, there's a lot of other apps that we use on our phone that we have used for a long time. And when we think about the things that we often go to our phones for, yeah, there's, you know, messaging, there's phone calls, there's communication, but there's also things like social media and games.
因此，同一研究中有61%的受访者表示，他们对发现在网上谁被自己吸引更感兴趣，而不是真正和任何人出去约会。显然，我认为我们需要对这一点做更多的研究，这将是一个非常迷人的后续研究。但我认为这个初步发现向我们展示的是，约会软件可能更多的是公共确认的来源，而不是实际的浪漫潜力。我有一个关于为什么会这样的理论，这与我所说的通过约会软件的存在将约会游戏化有关。我不认为那是故意的。你知道，我们手机里还有很多其他长期使用的软件，当我们想到我们经常使用手机做的事情时，是的，有消息传递、有电话、有沟通，但也有社交媒体和游戏等东西。
And these apps have been constructed to be highly addictive and to keep our attention by manipulating how we receive dopamine through likes and delayed gratification, flashy colors and short hits or kind of rewards. And so that pattern of consumption and that usage has been translated to how we approach dating apps. We now approach them like a game, like something to give us that dopamine through validation. And so we swipe and we swipe and we swipe and we swipe and we never actually do anything. Honestly, I think if you want any success, if you want to actually meet people, it might be frustrating to say it, but I think it's also obvious that you've kind of got to do the work. Like you have to be going on dates. Even if they might be horrible, they'll still be a really good story. You have to talk to people. You have to translate those connections to kind of real world. meet cutes. And that can be hard for some people. I really appreciate that. I think dating apps can make some people feel particularly down on themselves because of things like a high rejection rate. You know, not everyone you encounter is going to be a winner because each of these people has their own reasons for being on an app like Tinder or Hinge or Bumble. So kind of the nature of using these
这些软件被构建得具有高度成瘾性，通过操纵我们如何通过点赞、延迟满足、耀眼的颜色和短暂的刺激或奖励来接收多巴胺，从而保持我们的注意力。因此，这种消费模式和使用方式已经被转化为我们对待约会软件的方式。我们现在把它们当作游戏来对待，当作通过认可给我们提供多巴胺的东西。于是我们一直左划，一直左划，一直左划，一直左划，却从来没有真正采取任何行动。老实说，我认为如果你想取得任何成功，如果你真的想结识人，这话听起来可能让人沮丧，但这也是显而易见的，你必须付出努力。就像你必须去约会一样。即使它们可能很糟糕，但仍然会是一个很好的故事。你必须和人说话。你必须把这些连接转化为现实世界中的“不期而遇”。这对某些人来说可能很难。我非常理解这一点。我认为约会软件会因为诸如高拒绝率之类的事情，让一些人对自己的感觉特别低落。你知道，你遇到的并非每个人都会是赢家，因为这些软件上的每个人都有自己使用Tinder、Hinge或Bumble的理由。所以使用这些软件的自然属性就是
that people can drop off. You're going to get ghosted. People start dating others whilst they're still talking to you. And I think that that is actually quite confusing and can make us feel a little bit bitter. And that lack of repeat failure, it's not even a failure, maybe the lack of success or when you've had a string of bad dates or a string of people who have ghosted you when you really thought that you were getting along, that's pretty exhausting. And I even have a term for it. It's called date. dating app burnout. I've experienced it before. If you've listened to my life update that I did recently, you'll know that before I met my boyfriend, I was like, I'm never going on a dating app again.
人们会退出。你会遇到“被放鸽子”。人们在和你说话的同时还在和别人约会。我认为这实际上相当令人困惑，会让我们感到有点苦涩。这种反复失败的缺乏（甚至算不上失败，也许是缺乏成功），或者当你经历了一连串糟糕的约会，或者当你觉得自己和某人聊得很好时却被一连串的人放鸽子，这实在是太让人精疲力竭了。我甚至为此创造了一个词。它被称为约会软件倦怠。我以前经历过。如果你听了我最近做的生活更新，你就会知道在我遇到男友之前，我是那种“我再也不用约会软件了”的态度。
Like I'm not doing it. I'm so exhausted. I'm so sick of people not wanting anything. And if you're in that frame of mind right now, maybe it's time to change tact and take a moment to pause and focus on some other things or change your messaging approach. Better yet, match with some people that you typically wouldn't choose and just see what happens. Like you have nothing to lose. But that does actually bring me to my final element around the psychology of dating apps before we get into the second part of this episode. And I think it's really important to acknowledge some of the dangers, particularly around misogyny and violence towards women or other people. I don't really think I need to give you all a lesson in online safety
就像我再也不这样做了。我太累了。我厌倦了人们什么都不想要的状态。如果你现在正处于那种心态，也许是时候改变策略，花点时间暂停一下，专注于其他事情，或者改变你的发信方式。更好的是，和一些你平时不会选择的人匹配，看看会发生什么。反正你也没有什么可失去的。但这确实让我引出了关于约会软件心理学的最后一部分，在我们进入本集的第二部分之前。我认为承认其中的一些危险非常重要，特别是围绕厌女症和针对女性或其他人的暴力的危险。我真的不需要给你们上一堂网络安全课，
because hopefully we are all up to date, we're all up to speed on the do's and don'ts. And I would say that most people are generally pretty good people, but Stranger Danger is not a thing of the past. So I think it's important to do some of the basic investigative work before you show up at a bar at 2 a.m. to meet Mark, who was self-employed from a town you've never heard of. You know, dating app corporations haven't always been great at taking safety seriously, but one dating app that I think does and has done it really well is Bumble. And I want to quickly say this episode is not sponsored by them, by the way.
因为希望我们大家都跟上了时代，对该做和不该做的事都了如指掌，而且我认为大多数人总体上都是挺不错的人，但“陌生人危险”并不是过去式。所以我认为在凌晨2点出现在酒吧去见一个来自你从未听说过的小镇、自称自由职业的马克之前，做一些基本的调查工作是很重要的。你知道，约会软件公司在认真对待安全问题方面一直做得不是很好，但我认为有一个约会软件做得很好，那就是Bumble。我想顺便说一句，本集并没有由他们赞助。
I just think that each app kind of offers its own flavor of online dating. And when I was single, Bumble was personally one of my favorites. So when we come back, we are going to be talking to Lucille. She is our very own guest member of the Bumble team. And what I want to talk to her about is how to, A, make the most out of dating apps, and B, just make the most out of dating in our 20s in general. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我只是觉得每个软件都提供了各自特色的在线约会体验。当我单身时，Bumble个人是我最喜欢的软件之一。所以当我们回来时，我们将与露西尔交谈。她是Bumble团队的特邀嘉宾成员。我想和她探讨的问题是：A，如何充分利用约会软件；B，如何总体上充分利用我们二十几岁的约会生活。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。2%. 这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't. like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和姬姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是
Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode. where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
亚历克斯·恩格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马特·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我很乐意在白天谈论可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马特，这是第二集我们讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
欢迎收听我的新播客《用最难的方式去学》，我是主持人、你喜爱的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上活着的时候做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
你是一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任层次。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《用最难的方式去学》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Dating apps and the topic of dating apps comes up a lot. lot around dating in our 20s because I think of their popularity, their prevalence, more and more we're hearing that people are meeting their partners on dating apps. But I still think some parts of it need to be explored a little bit further from a psychological perspective, from a social perspective as to what the role of dating apps is now and how it's kind of replaced or compliments other ways of meeting people. And I thought, who better to have on the show than someone who knows this topic quite intimately. Today we are joined by Lucille and she works at Bumble as the communications
搜索《用最难的方式去学》并立即收听。在谈到我们二十几岁的约会时，约会软件和约会软件的话题经常被提及，因为考虑到它们的受欢迎程度和普遍性，我们越来越多地听到人们在约会软件上遇到伴侣。但我仍然认为，从心理学角度、社会学角度来看，约会软件现在的作用是什么，以及它如何取代或补充了其他结识人的方式，这些部分仍需要进一步探索。我想，还有谁比一个对这个话题非常熟悉的人更适合做嘉宾呢？今天我们迎来了露西尔，她在Bumble担任通信
director. Thank you so much for coming on. Thank you for having me. I feel like a lot of the rhetoric around dating apps comes from like the users and not so much from the people behind the scenes who have like brought these things to life. So can you explain kind of how the idea of Bumble came about and maybe also how it's different to the other apps? I know like it's the the, the, trifector of like Tinder Hinge and Bumble. How is Bumble kind of standing out from the crowd? Yeah, I think it's really interesting to look at sort of the genesis story of Bumble. And that happened nearly 10 years ago now when our CEO and founder Whitney Wulford had left
总监。非常感谢你能来。谢谢你邀请我。我觉得很多关于约会软件的言论都来自用户，而不是来自幕后将这些东西带到生活中去的人。所以你能解释一下Bumble的构思是怎么来的，也许还能解释一下它与其他软件有什么不同吗？我知道这类似于Tinder、Hinge和Bumble的铁三角。Bumble是如何在人群中脱颖而出的？是的，我觉得看看Bumble的创立故事非常有趣。那是将近10年前发生的，当时我们的首席执行官兼创始人惠特尼·沃尔夫离开了他曾工作过的
another dating app that she had worked for. And in the process of leaving that company experienced a lot of internet trolling, really saw the ugly side of the internet that we all have seen, but, you know, back then it was, you know, really dark. And so it really inspired her to think about, you know, why do we treat each other this way? Why do we allow this toxicity to exist online? You know, why do we treat each other a way that we just wouldn't treat each other in person? So while she is having this experience, she also has, you know, experience in dating and those two, you know, things kind of came together in her mind. At the same time as this was pre-Times Up, pre-Me-2,
另一家约会软件公司。在离开那家公司的过程中，她经历了许多网络恶意攻击，真正看到了我们都见过的互联网丑陋的一面，但你知道，在当时，那是相当黑暗的。所以这确实激发了她去思考，我们为什么要这样对待彼此？为什么我们允许这种有毒现象在线上存在？为什么我们对待彼此的方式，在现实生活中我们绝不会这样对别人？当她经历这一切时，她也有约会经验，这两件事在她的脑海中交织在了一起。与此同时，这是在Time's Up运动之前，Me Too运动之前，
pre-so many things that we know now when it comes to the conversation around gender. And she was thinking, you know, I know so many really successful women who are really smart and really powerful who won't ask a man out or who won't ask a man for their number in a bar who just have this like dating seems to be the place where we are still really traditional and still hold really traditional views. So all these ideas and experiences are kind of playing. around in her mind and that's where she comes up with the idea for Bumble because on Bumble in heterosexual matches women make the first move which means a man can't talk to you if you're a woman unless you make the first move first and invite that conversation and the philosophy behind
在我们所知的关于性别对话的许多事情之前。她在想，我知道那么多非常成功、非常聪明且非常有权势的女性，她们不会主动约一个男人出去，或者在酒吧里不会主动向一个男人要电话号码，只是觉得约会似乎仍然是一个我们非常传统并且仍然持有非常传统观念的地方。所以所有这些想法和经验在她的脑海中激荡，这就是她想出Bumble想法的原因，因为在Bumble上，异性匹配中由女性迈出第一步，这意味着如果你是女性，除非你先迈出第一步并开启对话，否则男人是不能和你说话的。这背后的哲学是，
that was if we change the way conversations start maybe we can change the way they continue and the way relationships build and sort of bake in kindness and respect and inclusivity into those conversations with the idea being that men historically face so much rejection in online dating that that feeling can inspire them to behave badly to be aggressive because they've been told they have to be aggressive they have to be the pursuer they have to do all of these things so by flipping all of that on its head how do we change the way that men and women interact with each other. And how do we hopefully create healthier and more equal relationships off the back of that? And, you know, that was, yeah, nearly 10 years ago. And there's been so many success stories since
如果我们改变对话开始的方式，也许我们就能改变对话继续的方式以及关系建立的方式，并将善良、尊重和包容“烘焙”进这些对话中，其理念是历史上男性在在线约会中面临着如此多的拒绝，这种感觉可能会激发他们表现糟糕、具有攻击性，因为他们被告知他们必须具有攻击性，他们必须是追求者，他们必须做所有这些事情。因此，通过颠覆这一切，我们如何改变男女彼此互动的方式？我们又如何以此为基础，创造出更健康、更平等的恋爱关系？你知道，那是将近10年前的事了。从那以后有那么多的成功故事，
Bumble babies and weddings and engagements and all these kind of things. I think that success has been proven in terms of both as a business and as a way of connecting people. But there are a few things that make, that's not the only thing that makes Bumble different. Women making the first move. also are known for our 24-hour timer. So the idea has always been on Bumble to actually get people talking. The idea isn't just to collect matches and have them sitting there. It's to actually get people talking and with the goal of meeting in real life. You know, I think that changed a lot during the pandemic,
Bumble宝宝、婚礼、订婚以及所有这些事情。我认为这种成功无论作为一项商业业务还是作为连接人们的方式都已被证明。但还有几件事让Bumble变得不同，不仅限于此。女性迈出第一步。我们还以24小时倒计时而闻名。所以Bumble的理念一直都是真正让人与人开始对话。这个理念不仅仅是收集匹配对象然后让他们闲置在那里。而是真正让人们开始对话，并以在现实生活中见面为目标。你知道，我认为这在大流行期间发生了很大变化，
which I am sure we'll talk about the impact of the pandemic during the rest of our chat. But, you know, the goal has always been to connect you with people in your area that you can meet when you feel safe. And the 24-hour timer is about making sure that people are actually starting conversations and going on dates and getting out there and meeting people. And if you're not familiar with what the 24-hour timer is, it means that in a woman has 24 hours to send the first message and the man has 24 hours to respond. And in matches between men and men or women and women or non-binary people and men and women, the 24-hour timer is still there. It just doesn't matter who makes the first move. So the idea is, yeah, to just get people talking and get people
我确信我们会在接下来的聊天中谈到大流行带来的影响。但是，你知道，我们的目标一直是将你与你所在地区的人连接起来，让你在感到安全时可以见面。24小时倒计时是为了确保人们真正开始对话、去约会、走出去并结识新朋友。如果你不熟悉24小时倒计时是什么意思，它的意思是女性有24小时发送第一条消息，男性有24小时回复。而在男性与男性、女性与女性、非二元性别者与男性和女性之间的匹配中，24小时倒计时依然存在。只是谁迈出第一步并不重要。所以这个想法是，是的，只是让人们开始对话并让人们
connecting, which I think oftentimes is what people, isn't necessarily what people associate with online dating. Yeah, absolutely. I feel like when I was, we were talking about this before, I am, I currently have a partner. So, but I've done my fair share of, of matching and swiping and, online dating and I found like the most infuriating thing about it was the use of it as like validation rather than actually for dating on both ends where it was like wow I just feel like all I'm doing is accumulating these people who like whose validation I guess I want and they're not really talking to them and I also think that giving women the agency to be like I'm going to choose who I want to speak to in my private life is so different to how we operate publicly where I think a lot of
建立连接，我认为这往往是人们并不一定将之与在线约会联系在一起的东西。是的，绝对的。我觉得当我在时，我们之前也讨论过，我现在有一个伴侣。所以，但我经历了相当多的匹配、右划和在线约会，我发现其中最令人恼火的事情是它被用作一种获得认可的方式，而不是真正为了双方的约会，就像是“哇，我觉得我所做的一切只是在积累这些人，我渴望他们的认可，却并没有真正和他们说话”。而且我也认为，赋予女性自主权，让她们能够选择自己想在私生活中和谁说话，这与我们在公共场合的运作方式截然不同。我认为在很多情况下，存在着一种非常传统、过时的观念，即男性可以随时随地接近我们，他们可以某种程度上打扰我们的空间，进入我们的私人领域，
the times there is this very traditional outdated idea that like men can approach us whenever they want and they can kind of interrupt our space and like come into our private sphere and like interrupt our lives and almost insist on some kind of romantic connection but I think the beauty of apps like Bumble is that it is no longer it's it's in the woman's hands who who who they decide to let into that space. So I think it's really, really cool. On a kind of like more general note, I think that the rise of dating apps
打扰我们的生活，甚至近乎坚持某种浪漫连接。但我认为像Bumble这样的软件的美妙之处在于，它不再这样了，它掌握在女性手中，由她们决定让谁进入那个空间。所以我认为这真的非常非常酷。从一个更普遍的角度来看，我认为约会软件的兴起
has really changed how we approach dating. For a few like psychological reasons, I think it gives us this sense of like abundance and infinite possibility. But then also kind of really has changed how we make decisions when it comes to our partners and the people we want to date in that we can be a lot,
确实改变了我们对待约会的方式。由于一些心理原因，我觉得它给了我们一种丰富感和无限可能性的感觉。但与此同时，它也确实改变了我们在选择伴侣和想要约会的人时做出决定的方式，因为我们可以更加……
quicker and discerning because of these online profiles and in a way that we maybe wouldn't be in our real lives or in an organic setting. And also this idea of like the choice paradox where like you're kind of overwhelmed by so many choices that you find it hard to choose someone. And I still think that they're yeah, it's really changed quite a bit. You have a perspective on what you think the major ways that dating apps have changed how we approach romantic connections, especially in our 20s? Yeah, I think that there's definitely valid arguments for the things you just mentioned about, you know, especially, you know, in markets where dating apps are really established and there's like large communities. You might feel like you're never going to get to the end of your, you know,
quicker and discerning because of these online profiles and in a way that we maybe wouldn't be in our real lives or in an organic setting. And also this idea of like the choice paradox where like you're kind of overwhelmed by so many choices that you find it hard to choose someone. And I still think that they're yeah, it's really changed quite a bit. You have a perspective on what you think the major ways that dating apps have changed how we approach romantic connections, especially in our 20s? Yeah, I think that there's definitely valid arguments for the things you just mentioned about, you know, especially, you know, in markets where dating apps are really established and there's like large communities. You might feel like you're never going to get to the end of your, you know,|||因为这些线上资料而变得更快、更具辨识度，这种方式可能我们在现实生活或自然环境中不会有。还有这种选择悖论的概念，就是你会被太多的选择搞得有点不知所措，以至于你很难选择某个人。我依然觉得它们……是的，真的改变了不少。对于约会软件改变我们对待浪漫关系的方式，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，你觉得主要的改变有哪些？是的，我觉得你刚才提到的那些观点确实很有道理，你知道的，特别是（你知道的）在约会软件非常成熟、拥有庞大社群的市场里。你可能会觉得你永远也看不完你的，你知道的……
swipe queue or all of those things. And you can't imagine there's actually that many single people in your area. Yeah. But I think the flip side of that is that dating apps have really enabled you access to a much more diverse pool of people than, I guess, we'll call it analog dating does. I think if you were to just date in the traditional way going out into the real world, you're actually quite limited in the types of people that you can meet. Because traditionally, pre-dating apps, most people met at work. Well, I work in PR, so I've never worked with a straight man. Really. So I'm not going to meet a man at work. You know, Bumble is like a female dominated company. I'm probably not going to meet a man here either.
swipe queue or all of those things. And you can't imagine there's actually that many single people in your area. Yeah. But I think the flip side of that is that dating apps have really enabled you access to a much more diverse pool of people than, I guess, we'll call it analog dating does. I think if you were to just date in the traditional way going out into the real world, you're actually quite limited in the types of people that you can meet. Because traditionally, pre-dating apps, most people met at work. Well, I work in PR, so I've never worked with a straight man. Really. So I'm not going to meet a man at work. You know, Bumble is like a female dominated company. I'm probably not going to meet a man here either.|||滑动队列或者所有这些东西。而且你无法想象你所在的地区竟然有那么多单身人士。是的。但我觉得它的另一面是，约会软件确实让你能够接触到比我们称之为“模拟约会”的传统方式更多元化的人群。我觉得如果你只是以传统的方式去现实世界中约会，你能够遇到的人的类型其实非常受限。因为传统上，在约会软件出现之前，大多数人都是在工作中认识的。好吧，我从事公关工作，所以我从来没有和直男一起工作过。真的吗。所以我是不会在工作中遇到男人的。你知道的，Bumble是一家女性为主导的公司。我大概也不会在这里遇到男人。
Yeah. And then, you know, through friends is the other way that people primarily met their partners. And what if you, all your friends don't have eligible friends to introduce you to? Or what if they're all married or what, you know, it's like you are limited by who's at the pub when you're at the pub or, you know, who's on the train that, like, looks nice. Whereas when you are online dating, you might have someone that lives next door to you that you never would have interacted with otherwise. And there's also research that's mostly come out of the US, but I think it would stand true everywhere, is that there's been a rise in interracial relationships since the rise of dating apps. And I think you could put that up to a number of things, but absolutely having access to a more diverse dating pool is a big part of. why you would see those kind of trends increasing, which I think is really positive. I totally agree. I feel like it's changed so much in the sense of like your, like, I always talk about this on the podcast, the idea of like your epistemic bubble and like your tribe. And that we are really quite happy existing in an established group and not really challenging that.
Yeah. And then, you know, through friends is the other way that people primarily met their partners. And what if you, all your friends don't have eligible friends to introduce you to? Or what if they're all married or what, you know, it's like you are limited by who's at the pub when you're at the pub or, you know, who's on the train that, like, looks nice. Whereas when you are online dating, you might have someone that lives next door to you that you never would have interacted with otherwise. And there's also research that's mostly come out of the US, but I think it would stand true everywhere, is that there's been a rise in interracial relationships since the rise of dating apps. And I think you could put that up to a number of things, but absolutely having access to a more diverse dating pool is a big part of. why you would see those kind of trends increasing, which I think is really positive. I totally agree. I feel like it's changed so much in the sense of like your, like, I always talk about this on the podcast, the idea of like your epistemic bubble and like your tribe. And that we are really quite happy existing in an established group and not really challenging that.|||是的。然后呢，通过朋友认识是人们结识伴侣的另一种主要途径。如果你的所有朋友都没有合适的朋友可以介绍给你呢？或者如果他们都结婚了呢，或者怎么样的，你知道的，这就好像你在酒吧时受限于酒吧里的人，或者，你知道的，受限于火车上看起来不错的人。而当你进行网上约定时，你隔壁可能就住着一个人，否则你们永远不会有交集。而且还有一项研究，主要来自美国，但我认为它在任何地方都成立，那就是自从约会软件兴起以来，跨种族恋情有所增加。我认为这可以归因于很多因素，但毫无疑问，能够接触到更多元化的约会对象是导致这类趋势增加的一个重要原因，我觉得这非常积极。我完全同意。我觉得它在很大程度上改变了你的——就像我经常在播客里谈到的那样——关于你的认知泡沫和你的社群（tribe）的概念。而且我们真的很高兴存在于一个既定的群体中，并没有真正去挑战它。
And our community is, and when we think about community, we think about work friends, we think about friends, we think about family, we think about colleagues, we think about acquaintances. It's not really larger than like 100 people. So I think it is one of those things where it's like, oh, great, now I don't just have to marry like the guy I met at church who my parents think is cool. Yeah, you're like, I can marry this like really cool DJ. I don't know, not that I would do that, but like, you know what mean? If you want, if you want, like, I've met on Bumble, I've met doctors, I've met DJs, I've met bar tenders, I've met, you know, people that work in advertise. Like, you know, you're, you can't really necessarily walk into a bar and walk up to a
And our community is, and when we think about community, we think about work friends, we think about friends, we think about family, we think about colleagues, we think about acquaintances. It's not really larger than like 100 people. So I think it is one of those things where it's like, oh, great, now I don't just have to marry like the guy I met at church who my parents think is cool. Yeah, you're like, I can marry this like really cool DJ. I don't know, not that I would do that, but like, you know what mean? If you want, if you want, like, I've met on Bumble, I've met doctors, I've met DJs, I've met bar tenders, I've met, you know, people that work in advertise. Like, you know, your, you can't really necessarily walk into a bar and walk up to a|||而我们的社群是，当我们想到社群时，我们会想到工作上的朋友，我们会想到朋友，我们会想到家人，我们会想到同事，我们会想到熟人。它其实不会超过100人左右。所以我觉得这是那种“哦，太好了，现在我不仅得嫁给我在教堂遇到的、我父母觉得很酷的那个家伙”的情况之一。是的，你会觉得，我可以嫁给这个超级酷的DJ。我不知道，倒不是说我会这么做，但是，你知道我的意思吗？如果你想的话，如果你想的话，比如我在Bumble上遇到过，我遇到过医生，我遇到过DJ，我遇到过调酒师，我遇到过，你知道的，从事广告工作的人。就像，你知道的，你不能不一定能走进一家酒吧并走到一个……
table of a doctor, a DJ, a bartender and a, you know, barista, you know, like, you're not going to find that, you know, and that's just thinking about occupation. That's not even thinking about, like, values or age or, you know, like a million other things that go into, like, what makes a compatible partner. Yeah, absolutely. And it's so interesting because people who've listened to this show for a while will know that I used to have such a stance against dating apps, which is ironic, I know. And the irony deepens when, like, I met my current boyfriend on a dating app. And, like, even the, like, and I kind of downloaded it and was like, oh, my God, this is the last time I'm ever doing this.
table of a doctor, a DJ, a bartender and a, you know, barista, you know, like, you're not going to find that, you know, and that's just thinking about occupation. That's not even thinking about, like, values or age or, you0 know, like a million other things that go into, like, what makes a compatible partner. Yeah, absolutely. And it's so interesting because people who've listened to this show for a while will know that I used to have such a stance against dating apps, which is ironic, I know. And the irony deepens when, like, I met my current boyfriend on a dating app. And, like, even the, like, and I kind of downloaded it and was like, oh, my god, this is the last time I'm ever doing this.|||医生、DJ、调酒师和，你知道的，咖啡师的桌旁，你知道的，就像，你找不到那样的组合，你知道的，这还只是考虑职业。这甚至还没考虑到，比如价值观或年龄，或者，你知道的，比如决定什么才是一个合拍的伴侣的其他上百万个因素。是的，绝对是这样。这太有趣了，因为听这个节目一段时间的人都会知道，我以前对约会软件持反对态度，我知道这很讽刺。而更讽刺的是，我是在约会软件上遇到我现任男友的。而且，甚至，而且我当时下载它的时候还想，天哪，这是我最后一次用这个了。
Like, because I had reached this sense of, like, fatigue around, oh, my gosh, I'm getting all these matches. but one of the things that I'm not getting is like, I'm not going on dates or like they fizzle out. And I think that's why the 24 hour thing is great. It's like, okay, well, then I don't have to worry about this person after 24 hours. They obviously, like, are not serious about me or about dating. So I think it really contributes to this like dating with intention model that we really promote on the show. One of the things, though, is like I said, this kind of burnout or fatigue from being on dating apps since I was like 18 and then like periodically being like, I hate this. But how can we move our conversations on dating apps to real world
Like, because I had reached this sense of, like, fatigue around, oh, my gosh, I'm getting all these matches. but one of the things that I'm not getting is like, I'm not going on dates or like they fizzle out. And I think that's why the 24 hour thing is great. It's like, okay, well, then I don't have to worry about this person after 24 hours. They obviously, like, are not serious about me or about dating. So I think it really contributes to this like dating with intention model that we really promote on the show. One of the things, though, is like I said, this kind of burnout or fatigue from being on dating apps since I was like 18 and then like periodically being like, I hate this. But how can we move our conversations on dating apps to real world|||因为我已经对这种感觉感到厌倦了，天哪，我得到了所有的配对。但我没有得到的一点是，比如，我没有去约会，或者它们就不了了之了。我想这就是24小时规则很棒的原因。这就好像，好吧，那24小时后我就不用担心这个人了。他们显然，比如，对我不够认真，或者对约会不够认真。所以我认为这确实有助于我们在节目中大力推广的这种“带着意图约会”（dating with intention）的模式。不过其中一件事，就像我说的，自从我18岁左右开始使用约会软件以来，这种倦怠感或疲劳感，然后周期性地觉得“我讨厌这个”。但是我们如何将我们在约会软件上的对话转移到现实世界中……
conversations, to real world kind of interactions? Because I think that was why I wasn't a proponent for a while. I now am a massive proponent. I think that they're a very important tool. But how can we kind of shift our online interactions with someone into a real world setting? Yeah. And I think what you just said that you downloaded the app, it was the final time you were going to do it, you'd had it, and that's when you met someone. that is not the first or the second or the third time. I've heard people say that is like, I just gave it one more crack and then I met this person
conversations, to real world kind of interactions? Because I think that was why I wasn't a proponent for a while. I now am a massive proponent. I think that they're a very important tool. But how can we kind of shift our online interactions with someone into a real world setting? Yeah. And I think what you just said that you downloaded the app, it was the final time you were going to do it, you'd had it, and that's when you met someone. that is not the first or the second or the third time. I've heard people say that is like, I just gave it one more crack and then I met this person|||的对话，转移到现实世界的互动中呢？因为我想这就是我有一段时间不支持它们的原因。我现在是一个坚定的支持者。我认为它们是一个非常重要的工具。但是我们如何将与某人的线上互动转变为现实世界的场景呢？是的。而且我认为你刚才说的，你下载了这个应用，这是你最后一次打算这么做，你已经受够了，然后就在那个时候你遇到了某人。这已经不是第一、第二或第三次了。我听过人们说，就像是，我只是再试了一次，然后我就遇到了这个人……
that's like now my husband, wife, partner, boyfriend, girlfriend, whichever it might be. And so I think it's really interesting to think about why that is so often the case and what you did differently that time around, you know, versus all the other times before where you downloaded it, how to go, like what was different in your attitude,
that's like now my husband, wife, partner, boyfriend, girlfriend, whichever it might be. And so I think it's really interesting to think about why that is so often the case and what you did differently that time around, you know, versus all the other times before where you downloaded it, how to go, like what was different in your attitude,|||他现在是我的丈夫、妻子、伴侣、男朋友、女朋友，无论是什么身份。所以我觉得思考为什么经常出现这种情况，以及那次你做了什么不同的事情，（你知道的）与你以前下载并尝试过的所有其他次相比，你的态度有什么不同，这真的很有趣。
what was different in the choices that you made, what was different in how you put yourself out there. Because there's a reason that story is really common, and I think it is because you brought a different attitude. Maybe you were less self-conscious. Maybe you were more outgoing. Maybe that final air attitude about you gave you an edge, you know. Or maybe you had a really clear intention, like,
what was different in the choices that you made, what was different in how you put yourself out there. Because there's a reason that story is really common, and I think it is because you brought a different attitude. Maybe you were less self-conscious. Maybe you were more outgoing. Maybe that final air attitude about you gave you an edge, you know. Or maybe you had a really clear intention, like,|||你做出的选择有什么不同，你展现自我的方式有什么不同。因为这个故事之所以非常普遍是有原因的，我认为这是因为你带了一种不同的态度。也许你没那么拘谨了。也许你更外向了。也许你那种“最后一次”的态度赋予了你某种优势，你知道的。或者也许你有一个非常明确的意图，比如……
I want to go on a date, I want to meet someone. I have a vision in my head of who the person is that I want to meet. Like it could be any of those things. It could be none of them. But what do you think it was? That is so interesting because I'm sitting here being like, wow, Lucila's like spot on right now. Because I think that I went into it being like, yeah, I'm not here to like fuck around. Like I've done the endless dates. I've done, I've had like my feral error. I've had my relationships. I've had my situationships. And I was like, what I really want to do is just like actually build a connection with someone. And so the people who weren't willing to do that or who were just like asking me like, you know,
I want to go on a date, I want to meet someone. I have a vision in my head of who the person is that I want to meet. Like it could be any of those things. It could be none of them. But what do you think it was? That is so interesting because I'm sitting here being like, wow, Lucila's like spot on right now. Because I think that I went into it being like, yeah, I'm not here to like fuck around. Like I've done the endless dates. I've done, I've had like my feral error. I've had my relationships. I've had my situationships. And I was like, what I really want to do is just like actually build a connection with someone. And so the people who weren't willing to do that or who were just like asking me like, you know,|||我想去约会，我想见某个人。我脑海里有一个愿景，知道我想遇到的人是谁。这可能是其中任何一件事。也可能都不是。但你觉得是什么原因呢？这太有趣了，因为我坐在这里觉得：哇，露西拉（Lucila）现在简直说到点子上了。因为我觉得我当时的心态是：是的，我不是来这里瞎混的。我已经经历了无休止的约会。我已经经历了，我经历过我的疯狂期（feral era）。我有过各种恋爱关系。我有过暧昧不清的关系（situationships）。然后我想，我真正想做的事情就是和某人真正建立起一种连接。所以那些不愿意这么做的人，或者只是问我一些，你知道的……
one word questions being like, why, who, what? Like, I just immediately was like, okay, I'm not interested in this. So I think that was one part of it. And then the person I'm now dating, like one thing that really set him apart was that he asked a lot of really interesting questions. And for anyone listening out there who's like, I want to connect with people on dating apps and have better conversations, he did this thing that was like, really got me where he was like, listen, I'm not going to ask, we're not going to start with a
one word questions being like, why, who, what? Like, I just immediately was like, okay, I'm not interested in this. So I think that was one part of it. And then the person I'm now dating, like one thing that really set him apart was that he asked a lot of really interesting questions. And for anyone listening out there who's like, I want to connect with people on dating apps and have better conversations, he did this thing that was like, really got me where he was like, listen, I'm not going to ask, we're not going to start with a|||单字问题的人，比如：为什么？是谁？什么？比如，我立刻就觉得：好吧，我对这个不感兴趣。所以我觉得这是其中的一部分。然后我现在的约会对象，他真正与众不同的一点是，他问了很多非常有趣的问题。对于在听节目的、想要在约会软件上与人建立连接并进行更好对话的任何人来说，他做了一件事，真的打动了我，他说：“听着，我不会问，我们不会从……
small talk. I'm going to ask you 10 serious questions and then afterwards we can talk about other stuff. And I was like, oh, and at first I was like, oh, this is a bit like intense. He didn't say it as intensely as I paraphrased it. But he then asked me like a series of really interesting questions and then he answered them in return. And some of them were like, what did you learn from your past relationship? What do people think of you? What do you think people think of you when they first see you, what is your best attribute, all of these things that I think we don't normally do in the small talk phase. See, that is hot. It was so attractive. I was like, did you say here you're talking about a man? I'm talking about man, yeah. So like men, like take note
small talk. I'm going to ask you 10 serious questions and then afterwards we can talk about other stuff. And I was like, oh, and at first I was like, oh, this is a bit like intense. He didn't say it as intentsly as I paraphrased it. But he then asked me like a series of really interesting questions and then he answered them in return. And some of them were like, what did you learn from your past relationship? What do people think of you? What do you think people think of you when they first see you, what is your best attribute, all of these things that I think we don't normally do in the small talk phase. See, that is hot. It was so attractive. I was like, did you say here you're talking about a man? I'm talking about man, yeah. So like men, like take note|||寒暄开始。我要问你10个严肃的问题，然后之后我们可以聊别的事情。”当时我就想：“哦。”起初我觉得：“哦，这有点太紧张了。”他说话的语气没有我意译的那么强烈。但他随后问了我一系列非常有趣的问题，然后他自己也回答了这些问题。其中的一些问题是：你从过去的恋爱关系中学到了什么？别人是怎么看你的？当别人第一次见到你时，你觉得他们会怎么看你？你最好的特质是什么？所有这些事情，我觉得我们在寒暄阶段通常都不会做。看，这太酷了。太有吸引力了。我当时就想：“你刚才说你谈论的是一个男人吗？”我谈论的是个男人，是的。所以男人，注意了……
and also women take note that these men are out there. Yeah, and like, for any gender, I was like, this is just like, I was like, if I ever have to do this again, like, this is a power play because I was like, it immediately cuts through, I think, all. of the, all of the weird awkwardness of matching with someone and being like, what do they actually want? Like, oh, is this just going to be another, like, fizzle? It's just going to be like another thing. Also, a great feature of Bumble is like, you have to answer within 24 hours. So it eliminates, like, having to stare at the people who've ghosted you. But I think the other thing that really changed for me and why that situation worked and why it was, like, the dating
and also women take note that these men are out there. Yeah, and like, for any gender, I was like, this is just like, I was like, if I ever have to do this again, like, this is a power play because I was like, it immediately cuts through, I think, all. of the, all of the weird awkwardness of matching with someone and being like, what do they actually want? Like, oh, is this just going to be another, like, fizzle? It's just going to be like another thing. Also, a great feature of Bumble is like, you have to answer within 24 hours. So it eliminates, like, having to stare at the people who've ghosted you. But I think the other thing that really changed for me and why that situation worked and why it was, like, the dating|||女性也注意了，这样的男人是存在的。是的，而且，对于任何性别，我都觉得，这就像是……我当时想，如果我以后还必须这样做的话，这简直是一个王牌手段（power play），因为我觉得它立刻打破了所有与某人配对后的那种诡异的尴尬感，比如：他们到底想要什么？哦，这会不会又是不了了之？这会不会又是一次无用功。此外，Bumble的一个绝佳功能是，你必须在24小时内回复。因此它省去了盯着那些对你“人间蒸发”（ghosted）的人的麻烦。但我觉得对我来说真正改变的另一件事，以及为什么那种情况行得通，为什么它是，比如，那个约会……
app, like why my final time using dating apps has proven successful this far is because I was like, I actually really know what I want now. And I'm able to very clearly, like, discern what they want from like certain things on their profile. So I think that like dating apps, if people answer honestly, also give you information that might be a little bit harder to get out. Like, do you want children? It's like that, those questions like, do you drink? are you looking for a long-term relationship or not? And immediately I was like anyone who was like just looking for fun or like short-term, not sure, I was like, no, I was like, if you're not sure.
app, like why my final time using dating apps has proven successful this far is because I was like, I actually really know what I want now. And I'm able to very clearly, like, discern what they want from like certain things on their profile. So I think that like dating apps, if people answer honestly, also give you information that might be a little bit harder to get out. Like, do you want children? It's like that, those questions like, do you drink? are you looking for a long-term relationship or not? And immediately I was like anyone who was like just looking for fun or like short-term, not sure, I was like, no, I was like, if you're not sure.|||软件——为什么我最后一次使用约会软件到目前为止证明是成功的——是因为我当时想，我现在其实真的很清楚自己想要什么。而且我能够非常清楚地，比如，从他们个人资料上的某些东西中辨别出他们想要什么。所以我认为，如果人们诚实回答的话，约会软件也会提供一些可能有点难以问出口的信息。比如，你想要孩子吗？就像那些问题一样，比如，你喝酒吗？你在寻找长期的恋爱关系吗？我立刻就觉得，任何只是想找乐子或者找短期关系、不确定的人，我都觉得“不”，我想如果你不确定的话……
Why waste your time? Yeah. And I think that's probably what you were doing previously is wasting a bit of time because you're like, oh, they look fun, they look hot, they look like they maybe have my shared sense of humour. But if they're also telling you in other ways that they're like not compatible for you or you don't want the same things, you know, but there's something about them that's like a bit of you,
Why waste your time? Yeah. And I think that's probably what you were doing previously is wasting a bit of time because you're like, oh, they look fun, they look hot, they look like they maybe have my shared sense of humour. But if they're also telling you in other ways that they're like not compatible for you or you don't want the same things, you know, but there's something about them that's like a bit of you,|||干嘛浪费你的时间？是的。我想这可能就是你以前一直在做的事情——浪费了一点时间，因为你会觉得，哦，他们看起来很有趣，他们看起来很性感，他们看起来可能和我有着共同的幽默感。但如果他们在其他方面也告诉你，他们和你不合适，或者你们想要的东西不一样，你知道的，但他们身上有些特质很对你的胃口……
then you're like, oh, I'll just chat. Or like, you know, those guys that give the one word answers, you're like, oh, I'm just going to persist. And it's like something really does change when you stop doing that. And you really look for the people that are giving you what you want. I love that perspective. Something that I get asked a lot that I think maybe you could shed some light on as like our dating up expert is these two conflicting.
then you're like, oh, I'll just chat. Or like, you0 know, those guys that give the one word answers, you're like, oh, I'm just going to persist. And it's like something really does change when you stop doing that. And you really look for the people that are giving you what you want. I love that perspective. Something that I get asked a lot that I think maybe you could shed some light on as like our dating up expert is these two conflicting.|||然后你就会想，哦，我先聊聊看吧。或者，你知道的，那些只用一个字回答的家伙，你会觉得，哦，我还是坚持一下吧。这就好像当你停止这样做时，真的会有所改变。而你真正去寻找那些能给你想要的东西的人。我非常喜欢这个观点。有一件事经常有人问我，我想作为我们的约会软件专家，你或许可以为此提供一些启发，那就是这两种相互矛盾的观点。
perspectives. So when I was single, I heard a lot, like, dating is just a numbers game. And then the other one was, it will happen when you least expect it. Both of those, I think those are two incredibly different perspectives. It's like, dating is a numbers game is like, you will reach a maximum, reach a number of dates, and then like the next one will be the right date. And then the other perspective is like, it's all up to fate. It's like fate versus like action and intention. do you think it's a numbers game? What would you say, like, as someone who is obviously working in the machinery of dating apps, what does the story you typically see?
perspectives. So when I was single, I heard a lot, like, dating is just a numbers game. And then the other one was, it will happen when you least expect it. Both of those, I think those are two incredibly different perspectives. It's like, dating is a numbers game is like, you will reach a maximum, reach a number of dates, and then like the next one will be the right date. And then the other perspective is like, it's all up to fate. It's like fate versus like action and intention. do you think it's a numbers game? What would you say, like, as someone who is obviously working in the machinery of dating apps, what does the story you typically see?|||所以当我单身的时候，我经常听到，比如，约会只是一个数字游戏。然后另一个观点是，它会在你最意想不到的时候发生。这两者，我认为这是两个截然不同的观点。这就好像，约会是一个数字游戏，意思是你会达到一个最大值，达到一定的约会次数，然后接下来的那个人就会是对的约会对象。然后另一个观点是，这一切都取决于命运。这就好比命运对阵行动和意图。你认为这是一个数字游戏吗？你会怎么说，作为一个显然在约会软件的运作机制中工作的人，你通常看到的故事是什么？
I think both of those things are true and both of them are incorrect at the same time for different reasons. And I think if we start with dating as a numbers game, it is true in the sense that you have to actually be talking to people in order to talk to someone that you like. You know, you have to actually be going on dates to meet someone that you have a great date with, you know. And not everyone is going to be for you and you are not going to be for everyone else. So in order to find the people that are for you and that you're for them, you have to, it is a bit of a numbers game. You know, it is a process of elimination.
I think both of those things are true and both of them are incorrect at the same time for different reasons. And I think if we start with dating as a numbers game, it is true in the sense that you have to actually be talking to people in order to talk to someone that you like. You know, you have to actually be going on dates to meet someone that you have a great date with, you know. And not everyone is going to be for you and you are not going to be for everyone else. So in order to find the people that are for you and that you're for them, you have to, it is a bit of a numbers game. You know, it is a process of elimination.|||我认为这两句话在不同的层面上既是对的，同时又都是错的。如果我们从“约会是一场数字游戏”开始说起，它在某种意义上是真的，因为你必须实际与人交流，才能和自己喜欢的人交谈。你知道的，你必须真正去约会，才能遇到一个能让你拥有美妙约会的人。而且并不是每个人都适合你，你也不适合其他人。所以为了找到那些适合你、你也适合他们的人，你必须——这确实有点像数字游戏。你知道的，这是一个淘汰的过程。
Like you have to be out there on the streets doing the work, you know. Yeah. Yeah, to be out of the house. You know, you have to get out there. You have to be the love of your life is not going to, like, be in your living room on a Friday night, you know, and find you there. You know, like you have to get out there and do it. Unless he's like a real weird. Yeah, and then you don't want him, you know.
Like you have to be out there on the streets doing the work, you know. Yeah. Yeah, to be out of the house. You know, you have to get out there. You have to be the love of your life is not going to, like, be in your living room on a Friday night, you know, and find you there. You know, like you have to get out there and do it. Unless he's like a real weird. Yeah, and then you don't want him, you know.|||就像你必须去街上做这些努力一样，你知道的。是的。是的，要走出家门。你知道的，你必须走出去。你必须——你一生的挚爱不会在周五晚上莫名其妙地出现在你的客厅里，然后在那儿找到你，你知道的。所以你必须走出去并付诸行动。除非他是个真正的怪胎。对，那样的你也不会想要他，你知道的。
Yeah. And then, but then on the flip side, you know, sometimes the first person you come in contact with is the right person, you know. And fate does have a role to play. I think that that really depends as well on like your beliefs, if you believe that there is one person out there that you're trying to find or if there are many possible ones for you, I think that like it definitely can't be understated, that feeling like of when you know that you've met someone.
Yeah. And then, but then on the flip side, you, know, sometimes the first person you come in contact with is the right person, you know. And fate does have a role to play. I think that that really depends as well on like your beliefs, if you believe that there is one person out there that you're trying to find or if there are many possible ones for you, I think that like it definitely can't be understated, that feeling like of when you know that you've met someone.|||是的。然后呢，但另一方面，你知道的，有时你接触到的第一个人就是对的人，你知道的。而且命运确实在其中扮演了一定的角色。我觉得这也真的取决于你的信仰，如果你相信世界上有那么一个你在试图寻找的人，或者如果你认为有许多可能的人适合你，我觉得那种当你意识到自己遇到了某人的感觉，绝对是不可低估的。
And fate has a big role to play in that. I don't, I think that really comes down to like whether you believe in, that our destiny is predetermined whether you believe that, like, big philosophical questions. But I think both are true. Like, you need to have faith that there is someone out there and that fate will deliver them to you at some point. But you also have to be in the game,
And fate has a big role to play in that. I don't, I think that really comes down to like whether you believe in, that our destiny is predetermined whether you believe that, like, big philosophical questions. But I think both are true. Like, you need to have faith that there is someone out there and that fate will deliver them to you at some point. But you also have to be in the game,|||命运在其中扮演了重大的角色。我不觉得——这其实归结于你是否相信我们的命运是注定的，是否相信那些宏大的哲学问题。但我认为两者都是真的。比如，你需要坚信外面的确有那么一个人，命运会在某个时刻将他送到你身边。但你同时也必须身处局中……
playing the game to win the game at some point, you know? I don't really like the game analogies, but like what I mean by that is you kind of have to hedge your beds and be participating in the process in order to get what you want out of it. And there'll be times when fate comes into it, but you still have to be in the running, you know? I really do agree with that, actually. I'm just full of agreements for everything you're saying. Because I think it's like, I also do believe that dating, especially dating with intention,
playing the game to win the game at some point, you know? I don't really like the game analogies, but like what I mean by that is you kind of have to hedge your bets and be participating in the process in order to get what you want out of it. And there'll be times when fate comes into it, but you still have to be in the running, you know? I really do agree with that, actually. I'm just full of agreements for everything you're saying. Because I think it's like, I also do believe that dating, especially dating with intention,|||参与这场游戏，以便在某个时刻赢得游戏，你知道的？我其实不太喜欢这种游戏的比喻，但我的意思是，你得做两手准备（hedge your bets），并且参与到这个过程中，才能从中得到你想要的东西。有时命运会介入其中，但你仍然必须留在竞争行列中，你知道的？我其实真的非常赞同这一点。我对你说的每句话都赞同得不得了。因为我觉得这就好像——我也确实相信约会，尤其是带着意图约会……
is a skill that you practice, especially like discerning what you want from someone, being able to set boundaries, knowing how to go on enjoyable dates, knowing how to get the most out of the experience is not something that we're just going to be like, oh, I go on like one date and a year and like, oh, it's terrible. Of course it's going to be terrible. In the same way that if you didn't talk to, if you didn't try and make new friends for a long time, you would probably really struggle having conversations with people you didn't have like a mutual shared history with. So I think you're right. It's like a component of both. And then sometimes it's just like the right person comes along and you're like, where have you been hiding?
is a skill that you practice, especially like discerning what you want from someone, being able to set boundaries, knowing how to go on enjoyable dates, knowing how to get the most out of the experience is not something that we're just going to be like, oh, I go on like one date and a year and like, oh, it's terrible. Of course it's going to be terrible. In the same way that if you didn't talk to, if you didn't try and make new friends for a long time, you would probably really struggle having conversations with people you didn't have like a mutual shared history with. So I think you're right. It's like a component of both. And then sometimes it's just like the right person comes along and you're like, where have you been hiding?|||是一种你需要练习的技能，尤其是像辨别你从一个人身上想要什么、能够设定界限、知道如何进行愉快的约会、知道如何从这段经历中获得最大收获，这些并不是说我们可以随随便便“哦，我一年只去约会一次，然后觉得：天哪，太糟糕了”。那当然会很糟糕。就像如果你很长时间不和人交流、不尝试结交新朋友，你可能很难和那些没有共同经历的人进行对话一样。所以我觉得你是对的。这是两者结合的产物。然后有时候就好像对的人出现了，你会忍不住说：你到底躲到哪儿去了？
Exactly. Where have you been? And I think like you don't always, like, realize that dating is a skill and meeting new people is a skill and dating is just meeting new people, you know? So the comfort level of like sitting down for a drink or a coffee or whatever activity you're doing with someone that you've never met, like that no matter how. confident you are, the first couple of times you do that, you're going to be like a weird and awkward version of yourself. So you have to get better at dating, you have to go on a few
Exactly. Where have you been? And I think like you don't always, like, realize that dating is a skill and meeting new people is a skill and dating is just meeting new people, you know? So the comfort level of like sitting down for a drink or a coffee or whatever activity you're doing with someone that you've never met, like that no matter how. confident you are, the first couple of times you do that, you're going to be like a weird and awkward version of yourself. So you have to get better at dating, you have to go on a few|||没错。你到底去哪儿了？我想有时候你可能并没有意识到，约会是一项技能，结识新朋友是一项技能，而约会其实就是结识新朋友，你知道的？所以，和从未见过面的人坐下来喝一杯、喝咖啡或进行任何活动时，那种舒适度——无论你多么自信，头几次做这件事时，你都会表现得像个古怪而尴尬的自己。所以你必须提高约会技能，你必须去约会几次……
dates and like practice that skill, learn, okay, what kind of questions do I want to ask? How do I want to answer those kind of questions? What are my good stories? You know, what is it? You know, it's like, it's dating in that sense is almost like public speaking, you know, or like presenting skills. Like, because there's not that many, aside from work, there's not that many other scenarios in life where you're pushed into a one-on-one situation with someone that you don't know, and it is a skill to develop. And it's actually a really great skill to develop. If you are really good at dating, that can build your confidence and help you in so many other parts of your life as well, because it is that skill that will transfer into meeting new people in any
dates and like practice that skill, learn, okay, what kind of questions do I want to ask? How do I want to answer those kind of questions? What are my good stories? You know, what is it? You know, it's like, it's dating in that sense is almost like public speaking, you know, or like presenting skills. Like, because there's not that many, aside from work, there's not that many other scenarios in life where you're pushed into a one-on-one situation with someone that you don't know, and it is a skill to develop. And it's actually a really great skill to develop. If you are really good at dating, that can build your confidence and help you in so many other parts of your life as well, because it is that skill that will transfer into meeting new people in any|||去练习这项技能，去学习：好吧，我想问什么样的问题？我想怎么回答这类问题？我有什么精彩的故事？你知道的，到底是什么？你知道的，这就好像，从某种意义上说，约会几乎就像公众演讲，你知道的，或者像演讲技巧。因为除了工作之外，生活中没有多少其他场景会把你推入与一个不认识的人进行一对一交流的境地，而这确实是一项需要培养的技能。这其实是一项非常棒的技能去培养。如果你非常擅长约会，这可以建立你的自信，并在你生活的许多其他方面给你提供帮助，因为它是一项可以迁移到在任何情况下结识新朋友的技能……
context. But it is something that you do have to, you know, have a go at and practice. And that's why it is good to go on dates, even if you're not like 100% sure that you really like that person. It's like, well, it's all good for the experience, you know. It doesn't mean like use people as practice dates. But you also never know, like sometimes, like I do this thing because I know we had, like, we were talking before about also like not feeling a spark and like I do this thing every single date I go on first date I sit down immediately and I'm like oh no like you know like really and I have to push through it because it's like this immediate automatic response where I'm like no matter if they look exactly like how I imagined no matter
context. But it is something that you do have to, you know, have a go at and practice. And that's why it is good to go on dates, even if you're not like 100% sure that you really like that person. It's like, well, it's all good for the experience, you. doesn't mean like use people as practice dates. But you and never know, like sometimes, like I do this thing because I know we had, like, we were talking before about also like not feeling a spark and like I do this thing every single date I go on first date I sit down immediately and I'm like oh no like you know like really and I have to push through it because it's like this immediate automatic response where I'm like no matter if they look exactly like how I imagined no matter|||语境中。但这确实是你必须（你知道的）去尝试和练习的事情。这就是为什么去约会是件好事，即使你并不是百分之百确定自己真的喜欢那个人。这就好像，为了积累经验，这一切都挺好的。这并不意味着把别人当作练习约会的对象。但你永远不会知道，有时候，比如我会这样做，因为我知道我们之前谈过，比如也没有那种火花，我每次约会——第一次约会时我一坐下来就会想：哦，不……（你知道的，真的）我必须挺过去，因为这就像是一种即时的自动反应，让我想：无论他们长得是不是完全和我想象的一样，无论……
if their voice is exactly like how I pictured it they're wearing exactly what I just get this immediate like oh no um got the ick and I have to push through it and it almost nine times out of 10, it like goes away after like five minutes of like sitting there talking to them. But it's almost like this weird automatic reaction where my brain's like, no, no, no, you don't like this person. It's so weird. But it's like you have to push through that kind of thing because I've had that with people that I've like gone on to have like relationships with, you know. So it's like we also have this kind of romantic idea. Like we're expecting like sparks to fly and fireworks immediately. And like that's not.
if their voice is exactly like how I pictured it they're wearing exactly what I just get this immediate like oh no um got the ick and I have to push through it and it almost nine times out of 10, it like goes away after like five minutes of like sitting there talking to them. But it's almost like this weird automatic reaction where my brain's like, no, no, no, you don't like this person. It's so weird. But it's like you have to push through that kind of thing because I've had that with people that I've like gone on to have like relationships with, you know. So it's like we also have this kind of romantic idea. Like we're expecting like sparks to fly and fireworks immediately. And like that's not.|||他们的声音是不是完全和我脑海中的画面一样，他们穿的衣服是不是……我就会立刻产生这种感觉：“哦，不，呃，有点倒胃口（got the ick）”，而我必须克服这种感觉。十有八九，在坐着和他们聊了大约五分钟后，这种感觉就会消失。但这几乎就像是一种奇怪的自动反应，我的大脑会说：“不，不，不，你不喜欢这个人。”这太奇怪了。但这就好像你必须克服这种事情，因为我和那些后来发展成恋爱关系的人也有过这种经历，你知道的。所以这就好像我们也有这种浪漫的想法。我们期望火花四溅，烟花立刻绽放。而这其实……
really reality. No. I think it's like about pushing through the discomfort and something else that really reminded me of. What you were saying is you don't really know what someone's like until you meet them. And I think that's the argument for using apps in a way whereby you're not just looking for online interactions. You're actually looking for like real life situations. Because once you meet them, I had this with someone I was dating previously where I was like, oh my goodness, like his profile was not amazing. I was kind of like, it's giving me the ick. But he like immediately asked me on a date and I was like, and I met him in person and
really reality. No. I think it's like about pushing through the discomfort and something else that really reminded me of. What you were saying is you don't really know what someone's like until you meet them. And I think that's the argument for using apps in a way whereby you're not just looking for online interactions. You're actually looking for like real life situations. Because once you meet them, I had this with someone I was dating previously where I was like, oh my goodness, like his profile was not amazing. I was kind of like, it's giving me the ick. But he like immediately asked me on a date and I was like, and I met him in person and|||并不是现实。不是的。我觉得这就像是克服不适感，而另一件事真的让我回想起你刚才所说的是：在见到某人之前，你并不真正了解他们是什么样的人。我认为这就是使用软件的理由，通过这种方式，你不仅是在寻找线上互动。你实际上是在寻找现实生活中的情境。因为一旦你见到他们——我以前和某人约会时就遇到过这种情况，当时我想：“天哪，他的个人资料真的很一般。”我当时有点觉得：“这让人有点倒胃口（giving me the ick）。”但他立刻约我出去，我想……我和他见了面，然后……
I was like felt a bit awkward and then suddenly it was like the best day I'd ever been on because I like forced myself out of my comfort zone. It's also something that I'm like, I also have to remind myself what I did when I was single is like, is this date actually interesting or am I just an interesting person? Yes. Because am I carrying this? Yeah. Am I carrying this?
I was like felt a bit awkward and then suddenly it was like the best day I'd ever been on because I like forced myself out of my comfort zone. It's also something that I'm like, I also have to remind myself what I did when I was single is like, is this date actually interesting or am I just an interesting person? Yes. Because am I carrying this? Yeah. Am I carrying this?|||我当时觉得有点尴尬，然后突然间这就像是我经历过的最棒的一次约会，因为我强迫自己走出了舒适区。这也是我常常会想到的事情，我也必须提醒自己单身时做过的事，那就是：这次约会真的很有趣，还是说我本身就是一个有趣的人？是的。因为是我在撑场面吗？是的。是我在撑场面吗？
is. And so one of my friends had this really, because we were talking about it a lot and she was like, you know, Gemma, your day job is talking to people for a living and finding, like, finding ways to make, you know, a topic accessible and, you know, speak to people. So of course, when you go on a date with someone, you're going to be applying that same skill that you have. And she said to me, she was like, when you're on a date, you need to think about how many questions has he asked you in the last hour, and it should be more than, like, I think five was her rule. And notice how many times you're genuinely laughing. And try not to, like, fake laugh out of politeness. Because I think that, like, humor and emotional compatibility and conversation are, like, the three bedrocks for
is. And so one of my friends had this really, because we were talking about it a lot and she was like, you know, Gemma, your day job is talking to people for a living and finding, like, finding ways to make, you know, a topic accessible and, you know, speak to people. So of course, when you go on a date with someone, you're going to be applying that same skill that you have. And she said to me, she was like, when you're on a date, you need to think about how many questions has he asked you in the last hour, and it should be more than, like, I think five was her rule. And notice how many times you're genuinely laughing. And try not to, like, fake laugh out of politeness. Because I think that, like, humor and emotional compatibility and conversation are, like, the three bedrocks for|||没错。所以我的一个朋友提出了这样一个非常——因为我们经常讨论这个，她就说：“你知道吗，杰玛（Gemma），你的正职工作就是靠跟人说话谋生，并且寻找——你知道的，寻找让话题变得通俗易懂的方法，并且（你知道的）跟别人沟通。所以当然了，当你和某人约会时，你会运用你所拥有的这项相同的技能。”她对我说，她说：“当你约会时，你需要考虑他在过去一个小时里问了你多少问题，这个数字应该超过——我想她的规则是五个。”并且注意你由衷地笑了多少次。尽量不要出于礼貌而假笑。因为我认为，幽默感、情感契合度和对话，这三者是……
a good connection. That's just my personal perspective. And she was, like, often as women, in particular, speaking as a woman, your first inclination is to like be really polite and really appease this person and make them think they're really funny and make them think they're really interesting. But it's like, no, when you're dating with intention, you're the one who wants to be satisfied here. Yeah. And I also do this thing where I, if I'm nervous, I will ask heaps of questions just out of like, it's almost like that nervous anxiety, like that energy that you get. And then it's easy to just do that nonsense. stop and then be like, hang on, this person hasn't asked me anything.
a good connection. That's just my personal perspective. And she was, like, often as women, in particular, speaking as a woman, your first inclination is to like be really polite and really appease this person and make them think they're really funny and make them think they're really interesting. But it's like, no, when you're dating with intention, you're the one who wants to be satisfied here. Yeah. And I also do this thing where I, if I'm nervous, I will ask heaps of questions just out of like, it's almost like that nervous anxiety, like that energy that you get. And then it's easy to just do that nonsense. stop and then be like, hang on, this person hasn't asked me anything.|||良好连接的三大基石。这只是我个人的观点。她说，通常作为女性，特别是作为一个女性来说，你的第一倾向是表现得非常有礼貌，极力安抚这个人，让他们觉得他们非常有趣，让他们觉得自己很有吸引力。但事实并非如此，当你带着意图约会时，你才是那个想要在这里获得满足感的人。是的。而且我还会做这样一件事：如果我感到紧张，我会问大量的问题，纯粹是因为——这几乎就像那种紧张的焦虑，就像你身上产生的那种能量。然后很容易就会做那些毫无意义的事。停下来然后想：等等，这个人什么都没问我。
And are they, yeah, what are we really getting at here? And I think that's the other thing when you think about dating with intention is like being clear on what it is you want is actually kind of a hard thing to do in your 20s because in your early 20s, it's going to be probably different in your late 20s and working out like what it is that you want to get out of a date. Is it just to like have fun and meet new people and learn things? is it to like find a partner because how you go about doing both of those things is very different. Also, it's experimentation. I think that's also why dating apps have a lot of merit in this
And are they, yeah, what are we really getting at here? And I think that's the other thing when you think about dating with intention is like being clear on what it is you want is actually kind of a hard thing to do in your 20s because in your early 20s, it's going to be probably different in your late 20s and working out like what it is that you want to get out of a date. Is it just to like have fun and meet new people and learn things? is it to like find a partner because how you go about doing both of those things is very different. Also, it's experimentation. I think that's also why dating apps have a lot of merit in this|||而且他们，是的，我们到底在聊些什么？我认为当你在考虑带着意图约会时，还有一件事，那就是清楚自己想要什么在20多岁的时候其实是一件挺难的事情，因为你在20多岁出头时的想法，到了20多岁快结束时可能会有所不同，弄清楚你到底想从约会中得到什么。是仅仅为了找乐子、结识新朋友并学到东西吗？还是为了找个伴侣？因为你采取这两种做法的方式截然不同。此外，这也是一种尝试。我想这也是为什么约会软件在……
in this day and age is because you really don't know what you want until you experience it and also until you experience what you don't want. And that is part of that is the value in meeting different types of people who you might otherwise not have interacted with who might be someone who you've maybe counted out in the past. Like I think that is so, so important. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
in this day and age is because you really don't know what you want until you experience it and also until you experience what you don't want. And that is part of that is the value in meeting different types of people who you might otherwise not have interacted with who might be someone who you've maybe counted out in the past. Like I think that is so, so important. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical|||这个时代有很多优点的原因，因为在真正经历过之前，你真的不知道自己想要什么，直到你也经历了那些你所不想要的东西。而这其中的部分价值就在于去结识不同类型的人，否则你可能不会与他们产生交集，而他们可能正是你过去曾排除在外的人。我觉得这真的、真的太重要了。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些不切实际的……
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,|||以及充斥着健康产业的过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信植物油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌失措的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或……
or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.|||任何你获取播客的地方都可以收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》的新一季中……我的天哪，这是同一个男人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.|||一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（double-tapped）小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.|||乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会在这里挑选一个话题，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的“快克”（crack）可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the same. second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, that you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the same. second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, that you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。所以，等你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,|||在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时……
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?|||我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得当你在人世间时，做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're free? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
Are you a good person because you're free? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that-s two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.|||你是因获得自由而成为一个好人吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真正的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, so we've obviously spent so many minutes talking about this. One thing we haven't talked about is being single and how we can get the most out of our single days, perhaps with the help of dating apps. So I know Bumble has this really cool, I guess, is it a feature or is it a, it's like in the app, it's Bumble BFF, right? Bumble friends. Yeah, so it's actually just relaunched its own new app.
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, so we've obviously spent so many minutes talking about this. One thing we haven't talked about is being single and how we can get the most out of our single days, perhaps with the help of dating apps. So I know Bumble has this really cool, I guess, is it a feature or is it a, it's like in the app, it's Bumble BFF, right? Bumble friends. Yeah, so it's actually just relaunched its own new app.|||搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。好的，我们显然花了很多时间来讨论这个。有一件事我们还没谈到，那就是单身状态，以及我们如何充分利用我们的单身日子，或许可以借助约会软件的帮助。我知道Bumble有一个非常酷的，我猜，这是一个功能还是一个，它就像是在应用里，叫Bumble BFF对吧？Bumble friends。是的，实际上它刚刚推出了自己的全新独立应用。
So it used to be a mode within Bumble that you could use for friend finding. And just last week, it's become its own app. So I think that is really one of the things that we're most excited about at the moment because a lot of our research from people in their 20s, like Gen Z people, were saying, like they want to make new friends, they feel lonely, they remote work and remote learning and all these things is like really impacted their ability to connect socially, platonically. So, I mean, we touched on this earlier, like the impact of the pandemic in a number of ways. When it comes to like platonic connections, people don't really know, like, where to go to make a new friend.
So it used to be a mode within Bumble that you could use for friend finding. And just last week, it's become its own app. So I think that is really one of the things that we're most excited about at the moment because a lot of our research from people in their 20s, like Gen Z people, were saying, like they want to make new friends, they feel lonely, they remote work and remote learning and all these things is like really impacted their ability to connect socially, platonically. So, I mean, we touched on this earlier, like the impact of the pandemic in a number of ways. When it comes to like platonic connections, people don't really know, like, where to go to make a new friend.|||所以它过去是Bumble里面的一种模式，你可以用来寻找朋友。就在上周，它变成了一个独立的应用程序。所以我觉得这确实是我们目前最感到兴奋的事情之一，因为我们对20多岁的人（比如Z世代的人）进行的很多研究表明，他们想要结交新朋友，他们感到孤独，远程办公和远程学习以及所有这些事情真的极大地影响了他们进行社交、建立纯友谊连接的能力。所以，我的意思是，我们之前也提到过，比如疫情在很多方面产生的影响。当谈到纯友谊的连接时，人们其实并不知道，比如，该去哪里结交新朋友。
And the interesting thing is a lot of, more than half of Gen Z people said they have made new friends online, but it's usually through social media or gaming or things like that. And not necessarily people that they can meet in person. and we've been talking a lot about how important it is to be able to connect in real life with people. And so Bumble for Friends works by the same way as Bumble Date, by connecting you with people in your local area who want to be friends. So if you're looking to expand your social network, do all these kind of things, make new friends, bumble for friends is the way to go.
And the interesting thing is a lot of, more than half of Gen Z people said they have made new friends online, but it's usually through social media or gaming or things like that. And not necessarily people that they can meet in person. and we've been talking a lot about how important it is to be able to connect in real life with people. And so Bumble for Friends works by the same way as Bumble Date, by connecting you with people in your local area who want to be friends. So if you're looking to expand your social network, do all these kind of things, make new friends, bumble for friends is the way to go.|||有趣的是，很多——超过一半的Z世代人表示他们曾在网上结交过新朋友，但通常是通过社交媒体、游戏或类似的事情。并不一定是他们能在现实生活中见面的人。而且我们一直在讨论能够在现实生活中与人建立连接是多么重要。所以“Bumble for Friends”的运作方式与“Bumble Date”相同，它将你与当地想要交朋友的人联系起来。所以如果你想扩大你的社交网络，做所有这些事情，结交新朋友，那么“Bumble for Friends”就是不二之选。
And then when it comes to romantic connections and dating with intention, we've also launched a feature called in-app speed dating, which is literally what it says. And it's a bit of a mix of like speed dating and blind dating where you play the game on Thursdays at 7pm. And it's blind dating. So you get matched with someone for three minutes and you can't see their photos or their name
And then when it comes to romantic connections and dating with intention, we've also launched a feature called in-app speed dating, which is literally what it says. And it's a bit of a mix of like speed dating and blind dating where you play the game on Thursdays at 7pm. And it's blind dating. So you get matched with someone for three minutes and you can't see their photos or their name|||然后，当谈到浪漫关系和带着意图约会时，我们还推出了一项名为“应用内快速约会”（in-app speed dating）的功能，正如其名。这有点像是快速约会（speed dating）和盲约（blind dating）的结合，你可以在周四晚上7点玩这个游戏。这就是盲约。所以你会和某人匹配三分钟，你看不到他们的照片或名字……
and you have to chat. And then at the end, if you both liked each other at the end of the game, you get matched. And then you see like their profile and their other information. So that's just like kind of a fun way of like getting you, getting people like actually talking to each other and dating because I think in this post-COVID world we're all a bit like we've all become a bit like insular and weird and we don't really know
and you have to chat. And then at the end, if you both liked each other at the end of the game, you get matched. And then you see like their profile and their other information. So that's just like kind of a fun way of like getting you, getting people like actually talking to each other and dating because I think in this post-COVID world we're all a bit like we've all become a bit like insular and weird and we don't really know|||并且你必须聊天。然后在最后，如果在游戏结束时你们互相喜欢，你们就会匹配成功。然后你就可以看到他们的个人资料和其他信息。所以这只是一种有趣的方式，能让你、能让人们真正开始彼此交谈并约会，因为我觉得在这个后疫情世界里，我们都有点——我们都变得有点封闭、有点怪异，并且我们其实不知道……
how to get out there so I think if you're feeling like you're looking for that kind of platonic connection in your life bumble for friends is a really great way to go and if you're really looking to get back into dating and want to go on some more dates want to talk to some more people in app speed dating is like kind of a fun way to like do it at scale, like talk to a bunch of people in one go and like say who you like and, you know, if you're feeling like, oh, I'm talking to these guys or girls or whoever it might be and I'm not really, you know, getting asked out on dates. Like, do the asking, you know, have a, have a thing where it's like, do you want to go see Barbie or Oppenheimer or whatever
how to get out there so I think if you're feeling like you're looking for that kind of platonic connection in your life bumble for friends is a really great way to go and if you're really looking to get back into dating and want to go on some more dates want to talk to some more people in app speed dating is like kind of a fun way to like do it at scale, like talk to a bunch of people in one go and like say who you like and, you know, if you're feeling like, oh, I'm talking to these guys or girls or whoever it might be and I'm not really, you know, getting asked out on dates. Like, do the asking, you know, have a, have a thing where it's like, do you want to see Barbie or Oppenheimer or whatever|||如何走出去，所以如果你觉得自己正在生活中寻找那种纯友谊的连接，“Bumble for Friends”真的是一个很棒的选择；而如果你真的很想重新开始约会，想去进行更多约会，想和更多人聊天，应用内快速约会就像是一种有趣的方式，可以让你大规模地进行——比如一次性跟一群人聊天，然后说出你喜欢谁，并且，你知道的，如果你觉得，哦，我在和这些男生或女生或无论什么人聊天，而我并没有真的（你知道的）收到约会邀请。那就主动去邀请别人，你知道的，搞一场——比如问一句：“你想去看《芭比》还是《奥本海默》或者别的什么……
your thing is or like there's a, you know, this is happening on the weekend. Like you want to come with me like just ask people out like I ask people out all the time and like the first time I did it I was like thought I was going to die of nerves and now I'm just like do you want to go for a drink on Thursday and if they say yes great if they say no cool like no skin off my nose you know you just it's a muscle you have to build and practice absolutely absolutely I do that well not anymore but I did I'd be like you know it doesn't really matter like I want to see this person I may as well do it and it's always so nice when someone asks you on a date so give that back to them as well um also i will say i used bumble bf when i first moved to sydney i had moved from cambra it didn't really have
your thing is or like there's a, you know, this is happening on the weekend. Like you want to come with me like just ask people out like I ask people out all the time and like the first time I did it I was like thought I was going to die of nerves and now I'm just like do you want to go for a drink on Thursday and if they say yes great if they say no cool like no skin off my nose you know you just it's a muscle you have to build and practice absolutely absolutely i do that well not anymore but i did i'd be like you know it doesn't really matter like i want to see this person i may as well do it and it's always so nice when someone asks you on a date so give that back to them as well um also i will say i used bumble bf when i first moved to sydney i had moved from cambra it didn't really have|||你喜欢的东西，或者像是有个——你知道的，这个周末有这个活动。比如你想跟我一起去吗？就像这样去约别人出去，我经常约别人出去，而且我第一次这么做的时候，我以为自己会紧张得要死，而现在我只是随口问：“你周四想去喝一杯吗？”如果他们说好，那就太棒了；如果他们说不，那也挺酷的，反正对我也没什么损失，你知道的，这只是一块你需要建立和练习的肌肉。绝对是的，绝对是的，我以前也这么做——好吧，现在不了，但我以前确实这么做过。我会想：你知道的，这其实没关系，既然我想见这个人，我不妨就这么做。而且当有人邀请你约会时，那种感觉总是非常美妙，所以也把这种美好回馈给别人。嗯，另外我要说的是，我刚搬到悉尼时用过Bumble BFF，我是从堪培拉搬过来的，当时其实并没有……
community and i was like i want to make friends from the comfort of my bed yeah no like in a way where it's like oh these are people that i might not interact with i might not run into them on the street i might not be doing that they might not be working with me and it was really really amazing and i think that a big part of being single is building community and building connection and building experiences and stories. And a lot of that comes down to, yeah, meeting new people. So I think that using features like BFF or just like a dating app to just go and have fun and just to meet new people, even if you're not looking for anything particularly serious, it's like super, super interesting. Wait, I have one more question for you. And I was just thinking.
社区，当时我就觉得我想舒舒服服地躺在床上交朋友。对，不是那种，而是那种可能会和现实中没机会互动的人交流，可能在街上碰不到，平时不会有交集，也不在一起工作的人。真的非常非常奇妙。我觉得单身很大的一部分就是建立社区、建立联系、建立经历和故事。而这很大程度上归结为——去结识新朋友。所以我觉得，利用像BFF或者仅仅是一个约会软件去放松、去结识新朋友，即使你并不是在寻找特别认真的关系，也是超级、超级有趣的。等等，我还有一个问题想问你。我刚刚在想。
this and I was like, I don't know if I know the answer to this. Do you use Bumble? Yes. Or is it weird? No, I do use Bumble. Um, I, it can be a bit weird sometimes. I do get asked every now and then if I'm like doing research or like, you know, spying on people, but I can assure you I am not. Um, and yeah, I ask people out all the time. I go on dates. I've gone on like three dates in the last three weeks because I just like ask people out and it really gets way less scary every time that you do it. So yeah, I would definitely encourage people to if they're feeling like, you know, we spoke a lot about dating with intention, but if you don't know what your intentions are, date different types of people, you know, if you've just always dated the same type of
这个，然后我就想，我不知道自己知不知道这个问题的答案。你用Bumble吗？用。还是说这挺奇怪的？不，我确实用Bumble。嗯，我，有时候确实会觉得有点奇怪。我时不时会被人问到我是不是在做研究，或者是不是在（你知道的）窥探别人，但我可以向你保证，我绝对没有。嗯，而且，我经常约别人出去。我经常约会。过去三周我大概约会了三次，因为我就是喜欢约别人出去，而且每次你这样做之后，都会觉得没那么可怕了。所以，是的，我绝对会鼓励大家，如果你们觉得——我们之前聊了很多关于带着目标去约会的事，但如果你不知道你的目标是什么，那就去和不同类型的人约会吧，你知道的，如果你总是和同一种类型的人约会
person and it's not getting you anywhere, just like go on a day. date with someone completely different and get out of this mindset that like going on a date with someone is like some kind of massive commitment like you can just go on a date with someone have a drink with them and like see where it goes you know but I think we kind of have this especially as women can get stuck in this idea of like oh maybe I'll like send the wrong message or this will happen or like then I'll have to do all this other stuff but you don't you can just go on a date with someone have a drink go for a walk in the park get a coffee do whatever and just just see how it goes, you know, and try and go outside your comfort zone and go outside your,
而且没有什么进展，那就去和完全不同的人约会吧，打破那种认为“和某人约会就是某种巨大承诺”的心态。你其实完全可以只是和某人约会、喝杯饮料，看看事情会怎么发展，你知道吗？但我认为我们往往会有这种想法，尤其是女性，容易陷入一种“噢，也许我会发出错误的信号，或者会发生什么，或者接下来我就得做一大堆别的事”的想法中。但你不需要，你大可以只是和某人约会、喝杯饮料、去公园散步、喝杯咖啡，做点什么都行，然后看看情况会怎样，你知道吗？试着走出你的舒适区，走出你
where you've traditionally sort of dated. And even if you don't meet the love of your life, you will have great experiences, you'll meet new people, you'll build those, that confidence, build those skills, and you'll probably have fun. And I think we just get so lost in all of the parts of dating that make it feel stressful that we forget that it's meant to be fun. And if you go in with that, even if you have the intention of finding a long-term partner, your short-term goal should be to have fun, you know, and to enjoy yourself and to enjoy your life. So have your intentions, but also make sure that you're enjoying yourself along the way. I think that is a great place to conclude. That is such an amazing advice. And I was like, I wonder if she uses Bumble because I was like,
过去传统的约会圈子。即使你没有遇到一生的挚爱，你也会拥有美好的经历，结识新朋友，建立那种自信、培养那些技能，而且你很可能会玩得很开心。我觉得我们太容易迷失在约会中那些让人感到有压力的部分里，以至于忘记了约会本来应该是开心的。如果你抱着这种心态去约会，哪怕你的目标是找到一个长期的伴侣，你的短期目标也应该是玩得开心，你知道的，享受当下，享受生活。所以，保持你的目标，但同时也要确保你在过程中玩得开心。我觉得这是一个很好的总结。这真的是太棒的建议了。当时我就想，不知道她自己用不用Bumble，因为我想着
maybe it would come off as like, oh, is this person like a scam? Like is she like observing us? I was like, I really want to know. So it's good to hear that you believe in, believe in the app so much. I do believe in what I'm selling, yes. Yeah, it's always a positive. It's always a positive. Well, I want to thank you so much for coming on today. It was amazing to have this kind of other perspective counter to like the user experience, but also the user experience, I guess. Yeah, it's a bit of both. It's a bit of both. Well, you're so welcome. It was so lovely to be able to talk to you. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-stop. our review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
也许这会显得……呃，这人是个骗子吗？她是不是在观察我们？我当时就特别想知道。所以很高兴听到你这么相信、这么看好这款软件。我是真的很相信我所推销的产品，是的。对，这总是积极的。这绝对是积极的。嗯，非常感谢你今天能来。能听到这种不同于普通用户体验、但又包含用户体验的视角，真的是太棒了。对，有点两者的结合。确实是两者的结合。不客气，能和你聊天非常开心。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。
Also, go on download Bumble. If you're single looking to mingle, I feel like you should give it a go. If you enjoyed this content as well, please feel free to follow me at That Psychology podcast. If you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to be part of the community, I always appreciate seeing you guys over there. And as always, if there is a friend who you think needs to hear this episode, Share it on. Share it forward. Share the joy. And we will be back next week with another episode.
另外，去下载Bumble吧。如果你是单身，想要拓展社交，我觉得你真应该试试。如果你也喜欢这档内容，请随时在That Psychology podcast关注我。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想成为社区的一员，我总是很高兴能在那儿见到大家。而且老规矩，如果你觉得哪个朋友需要听听这期节目，那就分享出去吧。传递下去，传递快乐。我们下周会带着另一期节目回归。
On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year.
在The Look Back at it播客里。1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过那段日子的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真的是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back At It。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何处理这些问题的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活。这向世界发出了一个信号：你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not. mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这段怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and build. and resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app,
在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、体能和意志力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《2%》
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts，或在任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。